[Musique]
non
lorsqu'une telle soirée en demie enfermé
chez christie's je sais que vous êtes
fatigué donc je vais faire très très
rapidement j'allais vous débarrasser
j'aimerais commencer ma soirée on fera
mieux ça tombe bien tous ceux qui ont
parlé aux parents des quelque chose de
crucial un moment ou à un autre on parle
d'éducation
je voudrais commencer par le cercle
familial qui est très important dans la
culture africaine
je ne saurais commencer cette soirée
sans honorer celle qui m'a donné et qui
pour la première fois participe à un
événement du victrelis 1%
celle qui baril a réparti le sacrifice
le travail bien fait et surtout le
principe tu lui demandent de l'argent il
ya un problème mais si tu lis demande un
vrai eva sortie longue liste mettre ton
nom ton appli naissance tous les traits
caractéristiques et qui est fait signer
oui c'est une question de plaisir
donc on n'a pas besoin d'apprendre le
principe est ma patrie c'est quoi ces
simplifications et ma ferme à gashi pour
le développement quand je n'étais pas
conscient quand on mange et il restait
de la nourriture dans le plat et le
partager en me disant qu'ils oublient et
en somalie et jean moulin dû faire face
il est souriant et à ma fille par jti
que je venais parler d'éducation
emilie mémoire c'est toi qui est
responsable mobilisation tu démarres et
d'éducation utilisez vous partagez soir
là parce que j'étais trop jeune bon vous
savez qu'il a indiqué je ne porte et or
général le dernier mais pas le moins
quand ils sont paul parle jamais d'eux
ce soir je vous le savez
particulièrement lui ce moment taille
est parti pour demander ma mais reflète
que je n'étais pas une femme à marier et
quand je suis sorti je tremble au fond
de moi qui vogueront dieu si ta propre
famille donne un bâton alors qui va
t'épouser pour te frapper nous avons en
afrique on n'a pas besoin de patent pool
de trappes et là c'est le comble c'est
cox il a lu dans mon regard
cette peur profonde il est dit en
sortant le départ tout ce dessin me dis
c'est que désormais je suis le zona de
défense messi aussi
je voudrais voir c'est 2 c'est mon
souffle
cette femme que vous voyez c'est ma
grand mère maternelle à l'été des
enfants les a nourris sans jamais d'où
ses petits-enfants pour le sache les
aider par ses enfants qu'elle n'a pas
bureau et sa scène altruisme à travers
son éducation et à utiliser au quotidien
d'un premier mari c'est en effet le bien
quand tu travailles tu auras m
parce que c'est pas toi qui les
chercheurs c'est que tu te cherches on
est quoi tir devant grand-papa lit les
maux qui affectent amis comme son nom et
des boutiques qui veut dire en été et
tout ce que vous faites
faites en sorte que ça soit clair et
honnête et c'est ça sonne au milieu il
me disait au quotidien ton savoir la
décence que ce que tu en font et où
tiens si on en perd seulement avec deux
jours se tiennent à la tête et sur les
critiques je me rappelle à quoi un bon
jour à ploeren je rentre à la maison
parce que on va rééditer l'informateur
parce que j'étais un enfant ibrahima
j'arrive hors droits ils auraient ils me
disent que tu tout mon amour pour toi j
j va il rentre dans la maison il sort de
leurs effets du temps à ma famille je ne
regarde pas en décembre de l'an
jay ahr est un modèle unique
oui je sais j'ai comme si des beats au
chili oui il dit et tout ce que dieu
aime plus que tout il fabrique saint
pierre et 6,5 alors j'ai ça qu'est-ce
que son pied moi l'estiment 2e
j'aimerais désormais j'étais une vision
elles m'ont déplu à la ville de new
marais persuadé supérieur à partie le
bec tu peux pas être au pied gauche
alors ces deux appuis je vois avec son
discours et où il m'a baisé multi début
2008 vénérable biti biti
chaque situation dans la ville et qui
mobilise et d'apprentissage
alors du coup pour être mieux j'avais du
boulot je paye normal je peux la cour
heureusement odeurs j'ai chanté de la
musique
j'ai fait la chorale bref je faisais et
je remercie jarvis est au bout et c'est
comme ça et de la confiance
si je commence à bâtir à bâtir jo a
construit des choses à music show est en
général estime de soi et la confiance en
soi
je connais par le cercle familial et
l'éducation qu'on veut bien nous arriver
parce que c'est une chose qu'il fallait
critiquer pour que nous sommes des
économies et lorsque j'entends encore
américains disent attendre 120 francs si
toi tu ne vois personne d'autre au monde
le bois et en afrique en particulier à
l'instant t
aujourd'hui pour nous sommes devant des
familles kitchen en premier la confiance
en soirée dans la vie des enfants et il
ya une chose qu'elle entend faire en
afrique est burkinabè qui bouge en effet
réfléchir autrement dire que la toute
petite par l'habilité modifiée qu'ils
inventent qui surtout par le professeur
qui n'a pas remisé à mort que si le
sacré la pensée critique c'est quand on
pense au dehors de la droite
parmi ces choses et concise peu
satisfait mort s'il me cherche
marion delà de ce que tu donnes compos
et l'enfant qu'ils cèdent devant réduire
le maître par se mettre à richard j
parce que d'eau qui vient de briller
filiation de compilation du corps
apprentissage ils sont devenus une
concurrence saine et pelletier namco
annonce nos écoles ici faut pas penser
je pense pour toi et gillett études et
si tu dana surtout à l'université avant
de dimako venir le voir
tu peux être sûr que tu vas passer
l'année sans jamais avoir à paillettes
ou quand la baraque en famille où tout
était fait mais n'en parle plus et
surtout la pensée critique et chimie
pour quelque chose
c'est la fille native et en cause en
dehors de la boîte auto show mais ça
pourquoi on se dit qu'il ya des choses
qui se font qu'ils ne sont à leur place
et on dit que la curiosité et robert de
la créativité
alors qu'en afrique la plupart du temps
être que mieux si ce n'est des choses at
il martelé
jane a failli tromper il pose trop de
questions et qui pointent vers une
manière binaire et quand on perd et
qu'on va ce qu'on voit au quotidien
alors en rêve
et on pique l'espoir chez les autres oui
on rêve on devrait apprendre à nos
enfants à rêver arrivées grand point que
leurs rêves leurs faces paix est
l'auteur disait et si tu rêves et étant
même le fait pas peur je ne sais pas
encore un bornage il faut que ça tes
frères et que tu ce saut et que tu
commences à chercher les mollahs et
quand tu rêves de type d'homme de
l'histoire autour de toi tu prends ta
vie en main tu prends celle des autres
en main alors du constructeur leadership
il se vouvoyer images des mois
j'accorde les oies pour une chose par
les warhol le leader tic du fonds m il
fait la place qui trace la route pour
les autres qui facilitent la vie qui
tire les autres chiens en afrique nos
leaders sont assis sur des peurs et des
dithyrambes al bachir est qu ils peuvent
pas bouger
donc on ne peut pas avancer et les oies
noah qui tirent ils fendent l'air quand
il est fatigué il va en arrière et
l'autre en arrière alors j'ai dit chaque
fois le leadership est à la vie ce que
le phare est au bâton sans le phare
aucun bateau n'a poste sans le
leadership nous y serons toujours un
arrière
et quand on prend ça vient mais celle de
la nation en main alors en devient
patriotes quand je dis par diop
attention ne confondez pas patriotisme
et nationalisme depuis l'insurrection
les devenus tous nationalistes au
burkina faso
houillon les mieux glisse boys à mon
honneur et vu la manière leur patriat
développe là me concentre et le
nationaliste la haine pour l'autre et
c'est cette chose qu'il faudrait prendre
laquelle on semaines et s'il chose que
l'école coloniale a décrite dans notre
situation on attend d'ailleurs souvent
des gentillesses qui a annoncé un enfant
faisait vivre son enfance à il va
grandir vivable oui comme le jour j qui
traditionnel d'avant tigre a dit si tu
apprenais mais bien sûr parce qu'il y
avait une initiation
c'était le moment où elle prenait la
parole donnée le maire
l'amour de la patrie les secrets de
tintin la force de l'eau le feu le vent
comment tu dois mourir dignement pour
doper vivre dans la dignité
mon grand père me disait tout le temps
et usé et dire tu as donné les prophètes
deux autres et à donner la connaissance
de la liste air aux africains tant qu'on
ne reverra pas et qu'on saura qu'on doit
le faire pour le bien de l'humanité
nous continuerons à être dernier parce
que le centre destiné à activer le monde
qu'on ne tire pas quand je repense
souvent dire les gens dire que l'afrique
est un continent maudit se dit mais non
l'afrique de l'enfant gâté de dieu on et
gâteries les oeuvres de will kill et
mary le garder dans profonde la santé
les parents aiment le pousse à qui on a
tant donné
c'est pas moi qui l'ait dire c'est vous
qui la vivent donc ces sites et
d'initiation ça nous apprenait notre
roller discipline le rôle que nous
devons sauver les couvents commandes lui
devant utilisera pour les autres c'était
l'initia sony nous apprenons aujourd'hui
l'initiation elle devenue mariage forcé
il existe à l'ordre et au delà ses
vêtements étaient là tout ce que j'ai
dit jusque là si c'était l'école
coloniale nous habitue l'école coloniale
cette usine à saucisse qui les fabrique
de même taille
le même talent inné mais c'est normal
en connaissez tous l'objectif
l'objectif de la colonisation on n'a pas
à leur demander de nous apprendre à nous
élever contre eux chers parents m'ont
redonné on a pris notre indépendance
mais dans la réalité les chaînes n'ont
fait que se déplacer de nos membres à
notre cerveau à notre club alors il faut
mettre le holà c'est le temps pour lui
dire si quoi la vision qu'ont notre
édification de nous stopper et de nous
dire si quoi le profil du fils pour moi
la vision et à la vie si keller à la
respiration la vision et au
développement
ce que l'air est à la respiration sans
vision il n'y a pas de développement
mais aucune visant les viable en actions
alors l'action elles pourront ici
nations ayant une vision d'anticipation
gm en afrique en décider qu'est ce que
nous apprenons à nous en faire après
l'on aimait enfant autiste et parce que
quand on existe voilà une raison de
vivre au pays en se posant la question à
savoir si je meurs qu'est-ce que je
reste annualisé qu'est-ce que je restais
l'héritage que j'ai dans la dignité
ce qu'on fait à l'apprenant nous apprend
à exister après ma mort être des
médecins et non en une heure des
médecins est remaniée sans se soucier de
chaque vie c'est de vivre au quotidien
pour sauver les vies de réunir médecin
c'est pour le prestige et l'argent et le
existent comme le titre de docteur deux
hommes après l'on a nos enfants
l'adversité mon ardeur maîtriser tous
les jours utilité tombés et naturel et
normal mais la décision de te lèves et
tu appartiens
tu peux décider de lever de dépoussiérer
et ne jamais donner la victoire deux
fois à donner mais parce que quand
l'automne il te fait du mal établissez
ça c'est sa première victoire
les sites changeant quelqu'un de mauvais
ça c'est la deuxième victoire et
washington et ça c'est la pire des
victoires que tu peux donner un polonais
apprenons à nos enfants à boisleux
possible dans les possibles d'ailleurs
le voit nos jeunes aujourd'hui
quand tu commences de cette difficile 10
passes l'entrepreneuriat ils aiment tous
l'idée d'entreprendre
on est les défis qui communiquent
apprenons à nos enfants la passion la
passion est à la vie c'était lui
l'essence à la voiture et lui la halle
aux moteurs tout récemment
tout le monde était content de fêter de
la pouvoir la poule à savoir 2 go le
fouquet arrêté désert
il a réussi parce qu'il était passionné
ce qui dope on voit ceux qui utilisent
rappelle se moquer de ceux qui utilisent
les autres téléphones
c'est de la passion de six blocs de bill
gates et ainsi de suite j'en passe
apprenons à nos enfants à s'approprier
leur irritation
la dame de ouakam maladie apprenons à
nos enfants
amenant le village à l'école apprenons
leur est pas passer ma l'architecte choc
à senna l'a posté de bobo dioulasso les
choses à burkina faso ce que c'est
apprenons leur investir à leur
développement personnel et en leurs
rêves apprenons leur à devenir des
apprenants et dans des films sans
apprenons leur à acquérir la
connaissance ils ont les diplômes c'est
vrai qu'au burkina les diplômes donne le
boulot de monde s'en fout de la
compétence
ouais je sais qu les multis moment ceux
qui seront heureux et réussiront sont
ceux qui apprendront à apprendre à
investir dans leurs connaissances et non
à leur diplôme
il faut s'approprier les à culture parce
que l'on boit la culture c'est notre
c'est la reconnaissance de soi et la
reconnaissance en l'autre d'ordre
notre autre soit à découvrir images il
était le passage à l'école on apprend
aux enfants notre santé
on aurait très peu de faux tire sur nos
différentes villes
quand j'entends dire les gens tirent et
les roses y sont ceux qui traitent mal
leurs femmes qui visait très mal
connaître la vraie vie tchô poser un
exemple de l'hiver c'est tout le
contraire donc apprenons à apprivoiser
notre culture
j'ai l'habitude de dire j'aime dire ça
parce que c'est ça ma culture
mon grand père marine getti tout le
temps je suis citoyenne du monde
habitant en afrique vivant au burkina
faso gelée qui veut dire le contraire
c'est son problème
comme disait mon grand père tu ne peux
jamais enlever de la tête de quelqu'un
qui pense de toi mais tu peux toujours
prendre de la hauteur
c'est qu'il pense lui appartient et
enfin soyons exemplaires
j'entends les gens dorment en amazone
enfin ne peut pas se comparer à nous qui
sommes ses parents mais s'ils ne se
compare pas les compare à qui vous a
légitimé pont digue est très puissant
si vous n'avez pas besoin départ qui
donne l'exemple ou deux des dirigeants
qui donne l'exemple
ouvrez le ciel on sait qu'il est
puissant il dit coeur clair selon
hachette demeurer chez davie faire se
dépoussière et comment sonne donc soigne
exemplaire donnant ce que nous voulons
être champion ce que nous voulons être
ce que nous voulons voir chez aux
enfants et c'est seulement comme ça de
nous aurons une société naquet nous
suivrons ou bien quand je ris rosetta je
pense avoue frère ma soeur m'a causé ma
tante analphabètes exclu qu'ils se
contentent du peu
alors que peut avoir mieux je demanderai
à chacun au quotidien de faire de sa
mission parce que l'utilisation de
l'afrique c'est pas comme c'est la
combinaison de l'école et de la culture
alors y pour qu'ils indiquent les vivre
la magie de la différence il l'humanité
je m'en vais
[Applaudissements]